yeah so how have you been it's been like
it's been like a good year
oh man um you know tired but good
tired but good i think could you be more
tired than last time i remember last
time you were like you're like grim
reaper has a part-time job and a
part-time job yeah you're working like
three jobs at the time right yeah it was
i was i was super busy but then i
finally got into a position where i
could you know focus completely on what
i'm doing now so i'm very lucky i'm very
lucky and um i'm glad that it turned out
that way because yeah i definitely would
have died which is ironic considering
who i am so it would have been a bad
situation um but
interestingly enough i feel now that i'm
like controlling my own schedule i'm
busier than i was before yeah yeah yeah
because you're filling in all the blanks
that's how it works you're like oh i
have one second free at this moment
perhaps i could schedule in the meeting
yeah i remember last time talking to you
you were just like yeah i'm working
three jobs um i you know i kind of feel
bad if i quit one and like i think it
took a month for you to realize yeah
that's just not doable that's just
something
that was a bad idea it's just impossible
it's a good thing to honor your
commitment yeah there's also a point
where honoring your commitments actively
[ __ ] yourself over yeah so you know you
can always just be like ah this just
isn't working out for me uh i'm gonna
i'm gonna not do this i think yeah but i
think last time you're on the podcast
you had like i think 300 000 subs or
something like that yeah how long have
you been doing
uh v tubing at that point how long had
that been i think it had only been about
like two or three months since we all
had debuted together yeah you were a
baby back then i remember like like i
think hollow live english just got
announced a few months before we started
filming that episode so it was like
super super fresh and now you're at like
how many subs now i think uh we just hit
one million seven hundred and fifty
thousand subscribers recently
i don't know
thank you i'm doing my best pretty
impressive after a year yeah like into
any capacity but i wish i could hit that
in a year oh my god
i do think a lot of it has to do with my
music personally um oh yeah yeah because
um i think that that's where the
majority of my fans come from in fact i
see a lot of comments these days saying
i don't really know what a youtuber is
but i like mori's music so that's
um that's always i'm happy to see that
as well does does it feel like a year
or does it feel like five years you know
it's like it's like it changes every day
like every day i feel a different way
about it like i feel like um maybe for
example yesterday i was reflecting back
and i'm like man time has gone by so
fast but the previous week i was like
man what a long year it's been have i
been doing this for five years maybe
yeah youtube is like a reverse
hyperbolic time chamber yeah yeah it is
it's like oh god i've been feeling like
i've done this for a decade it's like oh
it's been two months oh [ __ ] all right
yeah some sometimes as a youtuber it
feels like five years or five months i
can't tell sometimes i mean it must feel
like [ __ ] ages i've been for how long
now i feel like i've like aged 100 years
on youtube my god
there's some oh geez that's for sure
yeah yeah
oh sorry um actually forgot what i was
going to say now
i'm sorry
no problem man but i do have to say
though one thing that has really made it
seem like it's been a long time is
realizing just how little i knew at the
beginning
yeah yeah how much have you learned oh
god i mean honestly to be to be
completely real you guys you know as i
mentioned before i did a lot of music
stuff before this as well um but i feel
like this year i've put out more content
than i have in my entire career before
this year oh yeah yeah um and i really
learned a lot about like work ethic and
um you know what it means to
consistently put out content every
single day um yeah that's something you
don't really think about when you get
into the online like online creation
field right is that you kind of have to
it is a job and you have to schedule
your job just call god just call them
out
that's like content
content what what is that
what's that
i'm working on something big i swear to
god everybody maybe this fifth fate
video will be the one five months later
i feel like everyone has a different
like interpretation of what content
consists of
[Music]
like for example um i've seen plenty of
requests for a sleeping stream yeah
that's not really what i'm interested in
but i've seen plenty of others do it and
i guess how's that going well you've
done that you've done that yeah you know
when i see youtubers sleep i'm like oh
that's cheating that's yeah you get like
like come on unless unless there's a
chance that you could expose your bare
ass i feel like it's not really well
there's no danger there you know right
yeah i i feel like as a victor you could
uh cheat the system somewhere right
you know the model can just kind of prop
you know you have this wonderful ability
where you're not saying you would do
that
of course of course
you
have this amazing ability that when
they're not there they can still be
there yeah yeah so i feel like it kind
of takes away some of the magic of
sleeping yeah just sleep in another room
just put on a sleep track like snoring
in the background yeah yeah yeah it's me
i'm actually in another room i mean it's
scary though what if you sleep talk you
know you can't risk okay i did i didn't
okay i didn't move my mic just because i
yeah you know i didn't i don't want to
take that risk
you know i i i sometimes sleep tall i
sleep shout as well
i've been nervous i don't know what kind
of racist [ __ ] i'm shouting
i recently went on a a trip with chris
and he said that i woke up at night and
just like shouted and then like woke up
and then she went back to bed i shouted
are you okay i do that that happens yeah
it happens really yeah do you guys snore
back these w's in my dream sorry what
can i say
do you guys snore at all
when you sleep i want to tell you no god
but let's be honest i probably do yeah
you definitely do okay you definitely do
yeah um yeah all right
i remember it i think it was the
drifting special where someone was
snoring bad on the drifting special
because like
let's just blame chris anyway he's not
here let's play
who just like is the snore of the group
and it's it's always like a time limit
it's always like a race to get to sleep
before that guy starts snoring right
there's like multiple snorers there's
always like two level one people and
then there's like one level one hundred
percent
oh you're clearly making like ninety
percent of the noise what i hate is when
there's two people who like normally
they're just like level one snorers but
like for some reason when they sleep
together they feed into each other right
it's the resonance of the snoring
and it becomes like this like horrible
cacophony of like snoring actually how
do you know if you're snore though
that's the question
well usually like a partner tells you my
significant half tells me yeah same yeah
i'm just like i'm not recording myself
asleep
yeah has anyone ever told you if you
snore or if you sleep yeah sleep talk or
anything like that i went on a trip with
uh kiara a while ago we went to hokkaido
and she said that i just talked so much
in my sleep i do that to the time she
was like one night you sounded sad like
you were crying then one night you were
laughing and it was horrifying
wow those bars are just like constantly
covered
i mean i guess i could at this point i
did practice that song a lot it's like
she's speaking oh can you can you
perform rap god now let's see uh some
alum of the malama you assuming i'm a
human what i gotta do to get through to
you i'm superhuman innovative and i make
him
i don't have the lyrics in front of me
oh that was pretty [ __ ] impressive
they've been lying to me that i might
have known like it doesn't sound like
english you know you could have just
said yes
we
i mastered quote unquote mastered
godzilla rap god and the poker wrap and
interestingly enough the most difficult
of all of them was the poker app oh yeah
yeah yeah
how do you pronounce gyarados like
that's the interesting thing is that i
went on uh google sensei who told me
that the pronunciation is different uh
in american english and uh
uk english
i mean this we're talking about i've
always got it from the english dub which
i swear they say gyarados but the irish
stuff is never consistent but we're all
so stupid we're british yeah
i remember i remember like in the
english because there was like another
one that always gets heatly debated is
uh do you say growled on or do you say
grunon a groudon i've always wanted to
tell you
because in the anime they said two
different times i'm gonna show my age
now what's grew down
is that one of the newer pokemons
and groudon is like the the
guy on the front of the ruby cover like
that okay
yeah that's the blue one called uh
kyogre yeah
it's it's the [ __ ] uh stingray all
right
it's like that's just not a memorable
name for me right like lugia that's an
easy name to remember
like uh zapdos easy name to remember
like [ __ ] ruby sapphire past they're
just like i swear they're just using
welsh you know it's
how just like
supposed to remember this i mean you do
not want to play the newer ones the
newer ones are like do you like cleft
key
you know cleft key right which one is
that it's the key it's literally the
pair of keys the pair of keys
it's my favorite [ __ ] pokemon yeah
it's like an actual like strong pokemon
for like trolls yeah
oh that's kind of cool steel steel fairy
tale yeah i feel like they just dropped
a ball on the keyboard and i'm just like
yeah okay that's the pokemon name now
garba dose
garbage
[Laughter]
there's an ice cream one too oh yeah
vanilla ice yeah never out of ideas
no not vanilla eyes
that's around here i was gonna say this
character from jokes
[Music]
so sorry about this see that's why the
poker app is so hard though because i'll
think that i got through it i'll be like
oh yeah pidgeot and then the chat will
just be full of it's pidgeot you dummy
i guess we're starting over again great
that's the second to last name in the
poker wraps we get to start all the way
over how long is the poker app because i
assume you did the full version with all
151 150 yeah i think it's like three
minutes but it feels like 30. yeah they
put at the end of the episode yeah but
they only put like a small snippet oh
did they yeah yeah it's only like half
of them i think the full one is like
three four minutes online it's about
three to four minutes but you know the
hardest part is remembering how to
pronounce everything without people
being like hey that ain't right the one
line that always stuck with me during
the poker rap because like i grew up
with that [ __ ] is uh
did you perform a properly cali where
it's like the last line is like
charmeleon and then it's warthorte war
torture yeah they it's like they got
like a metal singer and it's like
only that part though it's like
chameleons
oh my god [ __ ] it what happened with
what's all the time you're making fun of
me
during the stream my chat was really
excited about that one part yeah yeah
i didn't know that
appears out of nowhere
i didn't know this rap song required
like a [ __ ] death growl and like a
metal singer
yeah
that's a fun song though it's a fun song
yeah because like i remember
i remember always trying to like learn
the poker app when i was younger and i
can't rap yeah as as we've all
established
good money to watch your childhood gone
in his mirror trying to sing the pokemon
wrap i would pay a lot of money for that
pleasure how many pokemon are there
nowadays 700 and something yeah
at which point do you guys recognize all
the pokemon no no i think i'm
i know what gen they're from yeah i i
can tell you what jen they're from but i
couldn't tell you their names yeah the
name's like impossible the names are
like hard mode but yeah didn't uh who's
that youtuber brian the guy who's from
polygon oh brian david gilbert he made a
new poker that had like all of them yeah
it was [ __ ] insane yeah like he he
like splits up to three separate like
parts of the song basically like he did
like every pokemon it was [ __ ] insane
he performed it live as well at a panel
which is like even more insane holy [ __ ]
pokemon now is eight hundred and
ninety-eight yeah see what boom is you
even being charged now 890. wow that's a
lot